[Music]
[Applause]
it's all powered by this 14 volt lipo
pack there are hidden switches all over
the suit like right here to the side
where my arms would be
I took this one to a costume Wraith
foggy and actually took first place on
this one and that motivated me to build
this one and that's important from Iron
Man to this one I took to my first con
Bowl soon of course that is actually my
first 3d printed helmet that I own and
this is the dream project gayathri that
I want to build one day how I got into
cosplay is kind of us at story a sad
beginning I was suffering from a deep
deep depression with a massive burnout I
was seeing a therapist at the time he
found out that I always had like a
creative side and I've always had a love
for comics so at one point he sent me
home with homework for the day to find a
way to combine my creative side and my
love of all things coming related and
sci-fi and see if I could like combine
the two and I just started building
[Music]